[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute netz
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
ein schonprogramm doch von mir wir haben
unter anderem diese themen für sie
100 milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
ampel und union einigen sich auf ein
sondervermögen damit steht die mehrheit
für eine grundgesetzänderung
neue sanktionen gegen russland auf dem
eu gipfel droht ein umfassendes
ölembargo zu scheitern und
wasserstoff aus wind und sonne auf der
hannover messe werben 250 aussteller für
grünen wasserstoff als alternative
energiequelle
es ist eine direkte reaktion auf den
krieg dass die bundesregierung enorm
viel geld in waffen und aufrüstung
stecken will nach wochenlangem streit
hat sie sich in der nacht mit der union
auf die details geeinigt so dass der
bundestag noch diese woche abstimmen
kann
dort hatte kanzler scholz das
sondervermögen in seiner zeitenwende
rede angekündigt ein weiter so könne es
für deutschland nach kriegsausbruch
nicht geben die 100 milliarden euro
sollen nun tatsächlich wie von der union
gefordert nur für die bundeswehr
ausgegeben werden der kampf gegen cyber
angriffe soll anders finanziert werden
christiane hübsche
die bundeswehr kann nun tatsächlich bald
groß einkaufen allein 20 milliarden
sollen für dringend benötigte munition
ausgegeben werden außerdem auf der
einkaufsliste us tarnkappen jets neue
transporthubschrauber bewaffnete drohnen
nachtsichtgeräte und schutzausrüstung
für die truppe
bundeskanzler scholz heute auf der
hannover messe begrüßt die einigung die
drei monate nach seiner zeitenwende rede
im bundestag kommt
die deutsche bundeswehr wird gestärkt
werden sie wird in der lage sein ihren
verteidigungsauftrag besser als jemals
zuvor
und sie wird ihren beitrag in der nato
leisten können die bundesregierung will
das sondervermögen im grundgesetz
verankern braucht dafür auch die stimmen
der union die hat jetzt zugestimmt und
durchgesetzt dass die 100 milliarden nur
der bundeswehr zu gute kommen wenn es um
so wichtige fragen geht dann muss taktik
und polit- und parteitaktik zurückstehen
diese einigung ist möglich geworden und
wir können jetzt den
gesetzgebungsprozess
auf die zielgerade bringen der
bundesfinanzminister legt keinen
konkreten tilgungsplan für diese neuen
schulden vor lindner trotzdem zufrieden
steuererhöhungen werde es nicht geben es
war ja gerade mein anliegen in dieser
diskussion dass wir ein sondervermögen
im grundgesetz verankern und damit
gewissermaßen neben die schuldenbremse
stellen das bedeutet dass es eine
einmalige ausnahme für diese
sondersituation ist der aktuelle
verteidigungshaushalt könnte anwachsen
auf rund 70 milliarden damit wäre das
zwei prozent ziel der nato erreicht eine
starre vorgabe aber sollte daraus nicht
werden wenn man 100 milliarden in die
hand nimmt je nachdem wie man es ausgibt
wird es in den nächsten jahren auch
momente geben wo wir die zwei prozent
sicher erreichen werden das ist
überhaupt keine frage aber das steht
jetzt nicht auf dauer als ziel im
grundgesetz noch vor der sommerpause
könnten bundestag und bundesrat das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
beschließen
fragen wir konnten banerjee in berlin
wird mit diesem geldsegen jetzt alles
gut in der bundeswehr also eine
finanziellen ausstattung sollte es jetzt
in den nächsten jahren nicht mehr liegen
aber damit das geld dann auch seinen
zweck erfüllt müsste die bundeswehr
jetzt zwei dinge lernen die sie bisher
noch nicht besonders gut beherrscht zum
einen muss sie lernen das geld schneller
auszugeben als früher das war bisher
nicht eine frage von wochen oder monaten
wie es ja jetzt zum teil geplant ist
sondern eher von jahren bei
großprojekten schon mal 10 bis 15 jahre
und sie müsste auch lernen das geld
effizienter auszugeben da blickt jetzt
heute nicht nur die ampeln mit sorge auf
das was man in der vergangenheit gesehen
hat entschuldigung nicht nur die linke
das ist die opposition die blickt mit
sorge auf das was man in der
vergangenheit gesehen hat die linke hat
heute gesagt dass es ein schwarzes loch
diese bundeswehr das immer wieder geld
versickert auch die ampel sagt da hat
man bisher keine besonders gute bilanz
da muss man auf jeden fall reformieren
und da wird also die
verteidigungsministerin jetzt vor der
aufgabe stehen diese reformen schneller
durchzuziehen als das geld ankommt damit
auch tatsächlich dann das was man in der
vergangenheit gesehen hat hin und wieder
massive verschwendung beim einsatz von
mitteln nicht wieder vorkommen denn
immerhin reden wir hier von 100
milliarden zusätzliche schulden die der
bund aufnimmt um die bundeswehr hier zu
modernisieren das muss dann auch
passgenau ankommen ist eine große
aufgabe die christine lambrecht da vor
sich hat und an der andere vor ihr schon
gescheitert sind die einschätzung
unserer hauptstadt korrespondentin
dankeschön chuck unterlag um den druck
auf moskau zu erhöhen versucht die eu
seit drei wochen ein weiteres
sanktionspaket auf die beine zu stellen
das sechste mittlerweile mit einem
ölembargo gegen russland doch vor allem
ungarn stellt sich quer jetzt sollen es
die staats und regierungschefs auf dem
sondergipfel richten aus brüssel florian
a
am morgen sind es ein paar demonstranten
in brüssel die ein embargo auf
russisches öl fördern am nachmittag der
ukrainische präsident sie lenski der
dieselbe forderung per videoschalte den
eu-spitzen direkt vortragen darf doch da
ist längst klar dass der sondergipfel an
dieser frage scheitern könnte auch wenn
sich der deutsche kanzler dessen
regierung bis ende des jahres auf
russisches öl verzichten will
unverändert optimistisch gibt man soll
nie einen tag vor dem abend loben aber
alles was ich wahrnehme ist dass das
wirklich gespräche gibt die mit dem
willen zu einer verständigung geführt
werden und das ist gut aktueller
kompromissvorschlag ein öl-embargo leid
zwei drittel des russischen öls kommen
derzeit auf dem seeweg nach europa für
sie soll das embargo ab ende des jahres
gelten nicht aber für das letzte drittel
das auf dem landweg über die druschba
pipeline nach ungarn fließt das land
soll darüber vorerst weiter billiges
russisches öl beziehen dürfen ist er mit
dieser ausnahme im boot nein
widerspricht ungarns ministerpräsident
viktor orban in brüssel wir brauchen
eine garantie dass sie im fall einer
störung dieser pipeline die durch die
ukraine läuft das recht haben russisches
öl auch auf anderen wegen zu erhalten
wenn wir das bekommen ist es gut die 2
noch also blockiert ungarn weiter nach
angaben von diplomaten dürfte es dabei
auch um finanzielle hilfen gehen eine
haltung die viele andere in der runde
zunehmend verärgert
ich wünsche wie das europäische land nur
an sich selbst denkt dann werden wir nie
vorankommen
eigentlich sollte dieser gipfel gar
nicht mehr über das öl-embargo
diskutieren jetzt dürfte der streit
darüber alles andere überlagern selbst
wenn sich die ungarische regierung noch
mit weiteren ausnahmen oder weiteren
millionen von einem öl embargo
überzeugen lässt dieser gipfel sendet
ein signal
die zeit großer europäischer einigkeit
angesichts des russischen
angriffskrieges ist vorerst vorbei
die russischen truppen sind in der ost
ukraine offenbar weiter auf dem
vormarsch der zeit sollen sie im don was
um die letzte größere stadt kämpfen die
dort noch von ukrainischen soldaten
gehalten wird im russischen fernsehen
reißt es sehr wie aero donetsk sei
inzwischen weitgehend unter kontrolle
pro russischer kämpfer diese bilder
sollen sie dort auf patrouille zeigen
die ukrainische seite bestätigt den
einmarsch und spricht von einer sehr
schwierigen lage
anders die situation im süden des landes
dort hat die ukraine mehrere dörfer in
der region person zurückerobert dürfe
die seit kriegsbeginn von russischen
truppen kontrolliert wurden unser
reporter johannes hano hat sich etwas
weiter nordwestlich auf ukrainischer
seite umgesehen rund um die orte banker
und plewka von denen es etwa 25
kilometer bis zur frontlinie sind
getroffen hat er menschen die mit
weiteren beschuss minen und
allgegenwärtigen mangel klarkommen
müssen
wir sind in der kleinen ländlichen
gemeinde blue chef gaben 25 kilometer
etwas sind es bis zur front die
russischen truppen konnten
zurückgedrängt werden aber ihre
hinterlassenschaften werden das leben
hier für lange zeit vielleicht sogar für
immer verändern
okay das ist eine grad-rakete weg hier
geht hin das auto an dem kleinen
minensuchtrupp hängt die zukunft der
gemeinde denn die felder und wiesen sind
übersät mit raketen granaten und panzern
ihnen immer wieder zerfetzt ist für die
auf minen treten
nur wo geräumt sein könnten die bauern
arbeiten eine katastrophe sei dass wir
die dörfer hier an der front sagte
swetlana wand zu lachen
wir können auf vielen beiden keinen reim
machen unsere kühe werden hungern wir
werden sie im winter nicht füttern
können
ihre kühe aber haben sie nichts mehr
wovon sie leben können auch aus der
kreisstadt bei starker wurden die
russischen truppen zurückgedrängt der
bürgermeister zeigt uns eines der vielen
probleme dass sie hinterlassen haben
praktisch alle apotheken seien zerstört
und er sieht fast so aus als sei dies
mit voller absicht geschehen
vor allem ein problem für die älteren
die auf medizin angewiesen sind die
lieferanten trauen sich nicht mehr zu
kommen denn wir sind hier im frontgebiet
- nach konter wie sony auf unserem
rückweg plötzlich schwere detonationen
und einschläge rund um die stadt
nikolajew 100 kilometer vor der
ukrainische einheiten drängen die
russischen truppen in der region carson
dorf im dorf zurück die russische
antwort massive artillerie und
raketenbeschuss heute wurde bekannt dass
die russische armee moderne schwere
raketensysteme hier an die südfront
verlegt haben soll die größte sorge der
menschen ist das russland zu einem
massiven gegenschlag ausholt und
russische truppen in die dörfer zurück
kehren
[Musik]
zurück nach deutschland erschütternde
daten zur kindesmissbrauch zeigt die
heute veröffentlichte statistik des
bundeskriminalamtes danach wurden 2021
im durchschnitt täglich
49 kinder und jugendliche opfer
sexualisierter gewalt und das sind nur
die fälle die der polizei bekannt sind
mehr als verdoppelt hat sich die zahl
der missbrauchsdarstellungen auf über
39.000 fälle aktuell gibt es auch wieder
ermittlungen in nordrhein westfalen mit
einer neuen dimension von brutalität
sagen die ermittler unter verdacht ist
ein 44 jähriger der seine opfer als
babysitter fand mit dutzenden weitere
männer habe er bilder und videos
getauscht bislang identifiziert 72
weitere verdächtige und 33 opfer ralph
goldmann
in diesem wohngebiet in wermelskirchen
in der nähe von köln griff die polizei
schon im dezember zu und nahmen den 44
jährigen fest auf seinem computer fanden
sie 3,5 millionen bilder und 1,5
millionen videos zwölf kinder soll er
schwer sexuell missbraucht haben die
hälfte davon noch nicht einmal drei
jahre alt manche noch säuglinge haben es
diesmal mit einer unfassbaren brutalität
zu tun die täter haben sich auf
barbarische art und weise an babys an
kleinkindern vergangen sie missbraucht
vergewaltigt gequält wir handeln dann
auch noch gefilmt noch nicht einmal zehn
prozent der daten sind ausgewertet doch
schon jetzt ist klar das material
enthält hinweise auf 72 weitere
tatverdächtige in 14 bundesländern und
weitere opfer
wir konnten 33 kindliche opfer
identifizieren aber wir sind damit noch
lange nicht am ende und wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass diese zahlen noch ganz
erheblich nach oben gehen werden es ist
bereits der vierte große
kindesmissbrauchs komplex der in den
vergangenen jahren in nordrhein
westfalen aufgedeckt wurde im gegensatz
zu anderen bundesländern sei dort sehr
viel personal und technik investiert
worden sagte bka präsident münchen heute
in berlin wir sind jetzt gerade dabei
solche instrumente bundesweit aufzubauen
sie auch zu vernetzen sodass wir auch
ein gleiches niveau überall kommen zu
den heute bekannt gewordenen fällen
dürften noch weitere opfer und täter
hinzu kommen die kölner ermittlungen
stehen noch ganz am anfang
die deutschen verbraucherpreise steigen
und steigen tanken essen alles wird
teurer wie seit 50 jahren nicht mehr die
inflationsrate sprang im mai auf 7,9
prozent eine entspannung des
preisniveaus ist nach einschätzung von
experten nicht in sicht zur entlastung
sollte ab mittwoch eigentlich der sprit
billiger werden aber das funktioniert
wohl nicht so wie gehofft zwar sinken
die steuersätze auf sprit um rund 30
cent pro liter benzin und um circa 14
cent pro liter diesel aber das tanken
wird dadurch nicht automatisch günstiger
frank bethmann an der börse in frankfurt
warum nicht weil die tankstellen wie es
heißt noch kraftstoff vorrätig haben den
haben sie noch zum alten steuersatz
eingekauft und wollen ihn nicht ab erst
im juni einfach verbilligt ab verkaufen
erst dann wenn sie selbst den steuer
reduzierten neuen treibstoff einkaufen
wollen sie die vergünstigung auch weiter
geben das kann dann doch noch einige
tage dauern und ob das dann auch
wirklich so passiert zumindest fraglich
finanzminister christian lindner brachte
sich per tweet heute gleich mal
einstellung wir lassen die
autofahrerinnen und autofahrer nicht
allein
dass der tank rabatt bei den menschen
ankommt das ist nun aufgabe von
kartellamt und co richtig
kartellamtschef andreas mundt ist
bereits in der spur sagt wir schauen den
über 14.000 tankstellen in deutschland
schon seit tagen auf die finger
schränkte aber ein das bundeskartellamt
kann die benzinpreise nicht vorgeben
unsere möglichkeiten sind begrenzt wir
sind eine wettbewerbsbehörde keine
kreisbehörde und so beschleicht einen
das gefühl dass bei den verbrauchern
weniger ankommt als möglich wäre
insbesondere wenn man auf die aktuellen
spritpreise an den tankstellen schaut
denn dort schossen die preise vor dem
rabatt noch einmal kräftig nach oben mit
den zuletzt leicht gestiegenen ölpreisen
dass sich das nur unzureichend erklären
dankeschön widmen
die energiewende weg von öl und gas
gewinnt durch die steigenden preise
immer mehr befürworter
eine alternative ist wasserstoff wird er
aus erneuerbarer energie wie solar oder
windkraft hergestellt könnte er vor
allem für die industrie die lösung sein
und so ist der wasserstoff in diesem
jahr eines der großen themen auf der
hannover messe oliver deuker berichtet
mit dem wasserstoff bus durch den
windpark in nordfriesland läuft ein
modellprojekt das größte dieser art in
deutschland
es soll zeigen so kann energiewende
gehen hier liefert überschüssige
windenergie strom für die produktion von
grünem wasserstoff der unabhängig von
russlands öl und gas machen soll
wasserstoff spielt eine ganz große rolle
im bereich der energiewende weil
wasserstoff wird dafür sorgen dass er
die die erneuerbaren energien viel
schneller in unser energiesystem auch
integrieren können klimafreundliche
grüne wasserstofftechnologie es ist das
thema auf der hannover messe ausgereift
ist die technik schon länger wirklich
durchgesetzt hat sie sich bisher nicht
warum zum einen das preisniveau der
grüne energieträger ist einfach bislang
teurer als das fossile ponto und der
zweite wesentliche grund sind wichtige
regulatorische grundlagen und beides
zusammen führte eben dazu dass bislang
nicht die hinreichende sicherheit für
investoren vorhanden war ein weiteres
problem es gibt zu wenig unternehmen die
bauteile herstellen die entscheidend für
die elektrolyse und damit für die
produktion von grünem wasserstoff sind
bisher war die nachfrage gering das
ändert sich gerade in dem ganzen thema
wasserstoffwirtschaft gibt es ein
herzstück das ist der stack der ist für
die elektrolyse wichtig und bosch sieht
sich in der lage den stack in großen
stückzahlen zu produzieren und damit die
den hochlauf der wasserstoffwirtschaft
voranzubringen
wasserstofftechnik unbegrenzte
möglichkeiten dieses flugzeug soll 2027
im markt eingeführt werden größere
maschinen sind schon in der planung
unter den opfern des flugzeugunglücks
gestern in nepal sind zwei deutsche das
hat das auswärtige amt bestätigt nach
dem absturz im himalaya haben
suchmannschaften 21 der 22 menschen an
bord tot geborgen ein passagier wird
noch vermisst die unglücksstelle liegt
auf rund 4000 metern höhe im norden wie
pauls
damit sind wir beim fußball norbert und
bei den wechsel wünschen von bayern-star
lewandowski ja da hat der weltfußballer
heute den druck erhöht und klipp und
klar erklärt er will weg vom fc bayern
geht gar nicht mehr lewandowskis vertrag
in münchen läuft aber noch bis 2023 die
vereinsführung will ihn nicht vorzeitig
gehen lassen
im polnischen nationaltrikot vor dem
länderspiel gegen wales schickt bayerns
torjäger eine recht eindeutige botschaft
in den freistaat
heute ist eins klar
meine geschichte bei bayern ist vorbei
eine weitere gute zusammenarbeit kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen
ich hoffe die bayern werden mich nicht
behalten nur weil sie es können
ein transfer ist für alle seiten die
beste lösung
bei meister in münchen will man von
einer trennung weiterhin nichts wissen
vorstands boss oliver kahn reagierte mit
unverständnis auf die aussagen aus polen
der bundesliga-torschützenkönig selbst
wirkte in der heimat heute nicht so als
hätte er große lust auf eine rückkehr
ins bayern trikot
der sc magdeburg hat die erfolgreiche
titelverteidigung in der handball
european league verpasst das team musste
sich gestern abend in einem packenden
endspiel gegen gastgeber benfica
lissabon ganz knapp geschlagen geben mit
39 zu 40 nach verlängerung
sind es noch fünf sekunden oder doch nur
drei in jedem fall hat magdeburg den
sieg vor augen lissabon muss sich was
einfallen lassen für die letzte aktion
und es gelingt den portugiesen ausgleich
zum 32 32 in letzter sekunde
verlängerung die spielerische
überlegenheit nutzt den
bundesliga-tabellenführer wenig benfica
angetrieben vom eigenen publikum gegen
die aufgerückten magdeburger zum 40 zu
38 die entscheidung ein hochdramatisches
ende in lissabon die portugiesen dürfen
jubeln der scm kann seinen europa league
titel nicht verteidigen ein kleiner
trost für die magdeburger am donnerstag
können sie vorzeitig deutscher meister
werden
ja das wäre doch ausweis die letzte
merkte bürgermeister schafft ist ja
schließlich schon 21 jahre dann drückt
mir die daumen zum schluss noch eine
höchstleistung aus der altersklasse 100
plus das ist die schwedin ruth las und
vor ihrem fallschirmsprung ein bisschen
hilfe braucht sie kurz darauf geht's in
die luft und dann ist er da der große
moment bei strahlend blauem himmel
runter komme ich immer wusste die alte
dame schon vorher perfekter flug saubere
landung die tandemsprung mit 103 jahren
ein neuer weltrekord
und singen kann sie auch nach dem kühlen
wochenende wird es diese woche wärmer
und morgen leider auch nass und
gewittrig wo genau sagt uns gleich katja
honnefer eben heute journal um viertel
vor zehn spricht bettina schausten mit
finanzminister christian lindner hier
übernimmt morgen jana park ist alles
gute ihnen und auch bald
[Musik]
guten abend ein bisschen unterkühlt geht
dieser mai zu ende und das bleibt auch
in den nächsten tagen in norddeutschland
eher kühl dann aber wird es von
südwesten schon deutlich milder mit
einem tiefer der iberischen halbinsel
auch am oberrhein gab es heute schon
wieder etwas höhere temperaturen als
noch gestern mit 21 grad in
norddeutschland blieb ist dagegen sehr
kühl bei 12 bis 14 grad immer wieder
zogen da schauer durch diese schauer
lassen jetzt in der nacht mehr und mehr
nach dann ist es zum teil klar es bildet
sich auch mal nebel und es wird kalt in
der lüneburger heide aber auch in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen sinken die
temperaturen bis 3 grad es droht also
nochmal bodenfrost milder bleibt die
nacht an der ostsee um ganz im westen
morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen an
der see bei 16 grad sonst werden 16 bis
21 grad erreicht die 22 bis 25 grad
beschränken sich auf die donau den
mittel und den oberrhein der tag beginnt
erst mal freundlich sonne und wolken
wechseln sich ab dann entwickeln sich
hier über der mitte aber auch richtung
nordseeküste schauer und gewitter und
zum nachmittag und abend dann auch aus
den alpen haus wechselhaft geht es dann
auch in den nächsten tagen weiter
freitag drohen unwetter guten abend